Les voy a contar una historia real
que empezó como una broma,
pero que se fue de las manos
y llegó mucho más lejos
de lo que teníamos pensado.
En 2008, un compañero de la carrera,
Fernando Cervera, y yo
creamos una página web.
En esa página web decíamos que existía
una nueva terapia alternativa
capaz de curar enfermedades
utilizando imanes mezclados con caca.
(Risas)
La feco-magneto-terapia.
Además, decíamos que
cuanto menos caca hubiese,
más poderoso sería el medicamento.
Si no había casi nada, mejor.
Además para consumir,
para facilidad del consumidor final,
venían en muchos formatos distintos,
por ejemplo, comprimidos, en jarabes,
en pomadas para la cara,
en inhaladores también...
y pusimos como pequeñas pistas
a lo largo de toda la página web
que hacían muy sencillo darse cuenta
de que eso era todo mentira.
Por ejemplo, dijimos
que los prestigiosos médicos
que habían inventado esta terapia
se llamaban Leslie Laurie y Hugh Nielsen.
A lo mejor les suenan los nombres
porque los inventamos mezclando
los apellidos de estos dos actores.
También poníamos fotos falsas.
Poníamos imágenes de ambientadores,
que claramente ponían
"ambientador de lavanda",
"ambientador de pino",
y decíamos que eso en verdad
eran pulverizadores de imanes con caca
que favorecían la sanación
de las enfermedades respiratorias.
Era bastante poco creíble ¿no?
Pues, fue una bola de nieve.
Al poco tiempo,
plataformas de venta online
ofrecían nuestros productos.
Nos entrevistamos
con otros terapeutas alternativos,
y no solamente no se daban cuenta
de que era un invento,
sino que nos ofrecían colaborar con ellos
y dar cursos en sus instalaciones.
Nos escribió un ex-asesor
presidencial de México
y nos pidió que el doctor Hugh Nielsen
escribiese el prólogo
para su próximo libro
de terapias alternativas.
(Risas)
También escribimos a todos los miembros
del Congreso de los Diputados.
Les preguntamos cuál era su opinión
sobre las terapias alternativas,
como la fecomagnetoterapia.
(Risas)
Ahí no tuvimos tanto éxito
porque solamente recibimos una respuesta
de una portavoz de sanidad
que nos dijo que ese tipo de terapias
deberían promocionarse
y estar cubiertas por la seguridad social.
(Risas)
También tuvimos otra
gran oportunidad que fue
la de participar en la feria esotérica
y de terapias alternativas de Atocha,
en la estación de trenes en Madrid.
El evento más grande de este tipo.
Ahí podíamos, si queríamos, poner un stand
donde vender nuestros productos
hechos con caca.
(Risas)
Pero no teníamos tales productos,
y además había que pagar.
Y la otra opción era dar una conferencia
explicando las bondades de la caca,
pero, claro, frente a una audiencia
alguien se iba a dar cuenta.
O no.
(Risas)
Dimos una conferencia donde
inventamos un montón de datos
como que los aborígenes argentinos
se frotaban caca
para curarse de enfermedades;
todo inventado.
Y no solamente nadie se dio cuenta
de que eso era mentira,
sino que nos invitaron a volver
a participar al año siguiente.
(Risas)
Toda esta experiencia
nos hizo poner en duda
todas las terapias alternativas
y a los terapeutas, evidentemente.
A nosotros nunca nadie no frenó el carro.
Nadie se extrañó de que dos veinteañeros
fuesen la máxima exponencia
de una nueva terapia que curaba con caca
en la península ibérica.
(Risas)
Nadie nos preguntó
dónde habíamos aprendido a curar
enfermedades, o a diagnosticarlas.
Existen muchísimas terapias alternativas.
Se ofrecen en farmacias, en clínicas,
en ferias, en universidades.
¿Alguien les preguntó
a esos terapeutas alternativos
dónde aprendieron a curar
o a diagnosticar?
¿Alguien les preguntó si eso que hacen
tiene alguna evidencia de funcionamiento?
Uno de los argumentos que van
a escuchar más habitualmente
es que esto no hace daño a nadie.
Él es Mario.
Mario en la época de la foto
estudiaba físicas
en la Universidad de Valencia,
mi universidad,
en el campus de Burjassot.
A Mario le diagnosticaron un cáncer.
Un terapeuta alternativo
le ofreció un tratamiento
que no tenía los efectos secundarios
de la quimioterapia.
Mario abandonó su tratamiento
convencional de medicina
y al poco tiempo murió.
Todos conocemos
a algún pariente, algún amigo,
que utiliza terapias alternativas.
A lo mejor esa persona
iba caminado por Atocha
el día que nosotros vendíamos
nuestros productos.
Somos muy exigentes
a la hora de hacer cumplir
los horarios del transporte público,
o de la cantidad de aire
que tiene una bolsa de patatas,
o la fecha en la que se van a poner
los adornos de Navidad este año.
Yo creo que deberíamos
ser igual de exigentes
a la hora de hacer cumplir las leyes
que deberían proteger
aquello que más valoramos:
nuestra salud.
Porque la permisividad que hay
frente a las terapias alternativas
a algunas personas
ya les ha costado la vida.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)